depuis sa réouverture le pôle jeunesse
de montigny le bretonneux accueille
trois jeunes pour les aider dans leur
recherche de jobs d'été pour ce jeune de
16 ans il faudra d'abord mettre à jour
son cv pour ensuite postuler pour mettre
plutôt l'objet de ta recherche parce que
le recruteur il veut savoir si tu
cherches un emploi ou juste un job
étudiant le monde agricole le service à
la personne l'hôtellerie le tourisme ou
encore la restauration sont des secteurs
qui recrutent beaucoup de saisonniers
cette année ces secteurs ont été très
impacté par la crise sanitaire et les
offres pour un job d'été se font rares
je pense ça va être beaucoup plus dur
parce que pour les commerçants les
entreprises
la conjoncture est assez incertaine déjà
ils n'ont pas beaucoup de visibilité si
ça va reprendre l'activité va reprendre
à la normale et même s'ils vont pouvoir
garder leurs salariés par la suite donc
les besoins saisonniers seront plus
restreint après ils peuvent avoir au
bout d'un certain temps avec un surcroît
d'activité besoin de personnel
occasionnel dans les bureaux d'île une
information jeunesse tout se passe à
présent sur les réseaux sociaux pour
s'adapter à la situation
les années précédentes le mois de mai
était décisif pour trouver une offre
d'emploi cette année les offres arrivent
au compte gouttes
on a toujours travaillé sur le sur des
forums avec du dating c'est à dire des
entreprises et les jeunes depuis de
nombreuses années on avait déjà commencé
à enclencher des réunions de travail
qu'on a dû annuler puisque les forums
n'ont pas eu lieu
on a voulu éventuellement leur est
organisé en juin juillet mais en fait on
n'avait pas de retour des entreprises
donc les entreprises sont en train de
reprendre leurs actes leurs activités
mais n'ont pas tellement de visibilité
donc en fait aujourd'hui au vu du
contexte c'est maintenant que ça se
passe en fait et c'est un petit peu au
jour le jour l'année 2020 s'annonce plus
compliquée pour la recherche d'un emploi
saisonnier
il faudra patienter et rechercher
activement sur les sites plateforme et
réseaux sociaux pour espérer trouver un
job cet été